what do you think will be the most
effective way
to deter vladimir putin
from an invasion of ukraine
vladimir putin is first and foremost a
kleptocrat
he's been in power as a dictator for 20
years he's stolen an enormous amount of
money from the russian state um from
russian oligarchs from from others in
russia
and that money he doesn't keep in his
own name he keeps in the name of
trustees i call them oligarch trustees
and those oligarch trustees don't keep
that money in russia they keep that
money in the west and as you mentioned
we see it in london we see it in new
york we see it in south of france and
putin values that money more than human
life he's killed a lot of people to get
that money
and so in in in my mind the the cleanest
safest and simplest way of deterring
vladimir putin from invading ukraine is
to go after his money and there's a
piece of legislation in place it's
called the magnitsky act it was named
after my
lawyer who was killed in russia sergey
manninsky and it allows the british
government
to freeze the assets and ban the visas
of people who are involved in high-level
corruption and human rights abuse
and so we have a tool the magnitsky act
we actually know who these oligarchs are
and hold putin's assets um we know that
they are held in in london and we know
that putin values his money and so the
easy way of doing things for us
and in a very asymmetric way as far as
putin is concerned is to freeze the
money of a certain number of oligarchs
and i would argue that we should do so
before he invades ukraine to show that
he were serious instead of waiting for
him to actually cross the border
do you think um
that
some of this has been done
already or is is your case is your
concern
that um the money is too important
to the uk you know the property the
investments and so on for us to really
do this seriously
well it's it's an interesting question
because on one hand um i would i would
i've seen and i think everyone else has
seen that um we've been pretty soft on
russia here in the uk
in the past they've committed
terrible atrocities using novichok and
salisbury and polonium in london
the russians have been
sending
jets over our uh you know military jets
in in the
uh over our airspace they've been doing
all sorts of terrible things um and we
haven't done much and and the reason we
haven't done much in the past is because
um of all this russian money sloshing
around and a lot of people close to the
center of power benefiting from it but
and this is a really important but um
we're now in a new world where where
russia is is threatening the stability
of peace in europe
and um and because all that money is
still sloshing around here it gives us
what i would call an enormous amount of
leverage we're actually we could
potentially punch way above our weight
because all that money is here and if we
started to freeze it and seize it i
guarantee you putin would pay attention
yeah but of course the the other way of
looking at this is there's all this
money sloshing around there are a lot of
people here benefiting from it and i
don't just mean you know um fat cats in
the city but i mean for example people
who might benefit from investment of
that cash
freezing and seizing the oligarchs money
is not
a pain-free process for britain is it
well well i i would argue that that is
is very pain free in the sense that that
they can't there's no there's no
reciprocal measure that they can take
against us so it's not as if we have all
of our money in russia they have all of
their money here and they could
reciprocate um this is something that we
can be done asymmetrical so and so we
can do it and there's no way that they
can retaliate against that and so yes
there are people um in in the city of
london and people in the house of lords
and and other places who are
beneficiaries of this money but the but
their interests
these people's interests are are so
trumped by by the interests of national
security that they if if they have
anything to say about this they should
just keep their mouth shut at this point
because putin is threatening the peace
peace and stability of the world
um you mentioned the house of lords now
of course we all have to be rather
careful about what we say about
individuals and so on but is your point
that you think that people in politics
including in our legislature are
benefiting from the money uh held by mr
putin's associates
there's no question that that's the case
um uh i've seen it firsthand uh members
of the house of lords from from both
major political parties were taking
money um from russians specifically um
to target the weakening of sanctions and
weakening of magnitsky sanctions and so
i've seen it
with my own eyes and that's just a tip
of the iceberg so yes there are many
people here who um do take russian money
um but at this point in time anyone
who's taken russian money should recuse
themselves from the conversation about
what to do about putin going forward
because we're now facing such a dire and
dangerous situation
let's trust talk this morning about new
uh legislation to
allow the government to take action
against uh putin associates
whether or not they were directly
involved in some way in the ukraine
situation uh do you think that's
necessary and a good thing
well um i'm glad to hear that and um
it's really that's the key point um i
don't think they actually need new
legislation the existing legislation
allows them to do that but if they want
new legislation so be it and and god
bless them for doing that
the key is to go after these people
because this is where our leverage is
and so it's a it's i'm very hardened uh
to hear hear her say that and and let's
hope that this thing uh the legislation
gets put in place and more importantly
that it actually gets used properly
because the the big the big problem with
these situations is um governments all
over the world always want to be seen to
be doing the right thing but often are
scared to do the right thing um to
really do the right thing one has to
make a list of the top 50 um oligarchs
who are looking after putin's money and
then start to sanction them and and
everybody who's involved in that knows
how angry putin will get and they're
kind of scared of making him angry but
this is the one thing that he'll listen
to
you um
mentioned earlier on in this
conversation
your lawyer and i think your friend
sergey magnitsky who was killed
in 2009
um
the sanctions against russia
bear his name
but
mr putin is still where he is he still
all seems all powerful
how do you feel about the fact that
somehow
nothing seems to be able to shift this
guy
well um
it's very frustrating to watch um putin
carrying on just getting stronger and
stronger um
and it's also frustrating that having
passed the magnitsky act
in the uk and actually in 33 other
countries
is not more readily used because
we know that this works and we know it
works because putin got so furious about
it when it first was passed in the
united states and in other countries
in the united states after it was passed
he banned the adoption of russian
orphans by american families and made it
his single largest foreign policy
priority to repeal the magnitsky act and
he's been following me all around the
world um trying to do whatever he can to
stop the magnitsky act from being passed
he sent one of his emissaries to trump
tower shortly before donald trump was
elected trying to get the magnitsky act
repealed and so we know that this is
something he cares about um everybody
who's involved um in russian opposition
uh in russian politics who aren't there
understand that this is the tool to get
him this is putin's achilles heel um
this is what he really cares about and
so it's really a question of
using this tool now
instead of just having it and and if we
use it properly and if we use it against
these oligarchs it will stop him